all right
movie retrospective time once again
going back to 1979
the one that kind of won the patreon
poll even though it was a tie but we
already did andromeda strain
on matinee because i said we were going
to do them both this is the 1979
when a stranger calls yeah i saw it when
i saw it on hbo
yeah jumped up here yeah pookie's up
here so if you see like a little butt
wiggling see that's a thicker butt
everybody knows what her butt looks like
i saw this and i remembered that first
scene you know with somebody calling her
from inside the house
and that really stuck with me the rest
of the movie i forgot about
and i think a lot of people have the
same thing i did as well because i
saw this movie also when i was younger
and i think i saw it on cable
and man that first 20 minutes with carol
kane and like the guy calling
it's like have you checked the children
and stuff that is [ __ ] dynamite right
yeah and i thought that was the whole
movie yeah that should have been the
whole movie
well okay so this is what ended up
happening with this and why this movie
ended up like that
so uh the writer director fred walton
well he's the director and he's the
co-writer like the other co-writer was
steve feek i don't want to like
you know shaft anybody in that regard
but they had made uh in the 70s they had
made a short film
that was called the sitter and it was
based on the very popular
urban legend which had been around for
[ __ ] decades which also was taken
advantage of in
black christmas in 1974 the whole prank
caller and then callers coming from
inside the house blah blah blah so like
i said that wasn't a new concept it had
been done in the movies before
it was a very popular urban legend but
they made a short film
that was called the sitter that was
about this urban legend and it got
so much um publicity and like a really
lot of people dug it and it even got
played like in
you know before other movies and stuff
so it was kind of
well regarded and it was yeah what i
said it was really scary
so i guess after halloween came out john
carpenter's halloween obviously from
1978
he was like well maybe we can take this
same concept because you know halloween
was originally called the babysitter
murders
and you know flesh it out to a
full-length film so that's what they did
so basically the thing about it so
so yeah so the first time i saw this
movie the first 20 minutes of it
like with carol kane in the house and
the guy calling have you checked the
children all this other stuff
is that 20 minutes is probably one of
the best
like suspense like creepy suspense
sequences like in any horror movie of
that era
it's just so well done the
cinematography is amazing even though
like the
this was like that cinematographer's
like his first uh
movie that he had done and he actually
went on to do much uh greater things as
well
but so that's i feel like that part of
the movie
is is really iconic and that people
forget that there's
other [ __ ] that happens this movie after
that that's only the first 20 minutes of
the movie
be honest the rest of it's forgettable
sadly it is i mean the last
act of it is good because it goes back
to the original character
but all the stuff in the middle um it's
not terrible because it's like it's got
great actors in it it's got [ __ ]
uh charles derning it's got um uh
colleen dewhurst
it's got all this other kind of stuff
but i think it loses a lot of its
narrative focus
you could cut it all out and just put
the end on there and
it would wrap up pretty quickly in about
a half hour
it probably well like i said originally
this was a short film yeah you know what
i mean that was just like the beginning
i had done it yeah i'm sorry just you
know
well yeah i on to be honest with you um
that's this
the pretty much the uh exact same uh
opinion of most horror movie reviews
okay um even one i was watching one girl
that had watched uh she was doing a
comparison because they did a remake of
this in 2006.
but she got mad yeah when i told her to
stop stop
telling me what to do yeah she's gonna
go right back to doing it okay go ahead
do it there tear it up i don't care but
yeah i mean this
uh it did really well at the box office
but yeah what i was saying was that i
had i was watching this video of this
girl that was
younger and she had watched the original
from 1979 and they also did a remake of
it in 2006 and she was like comparing
and contrasting them
and she said pretty much what we said
she's like the original she's like the
first 20 minutes
dynamite uh the middle part the end
pretty good uh she's like she's like so
when after
i watched it she was like i was kind of
like well um if it was me
i would have taken the part with the
babysitter and made that whole movie
like you could flesh it out obviously
you'd have to make it movie length
she's like but then i watched the remake
from 2006 which essentially
did that very thing like they kind of
took out most of the [ __ ] about
charles darning uh character like
chasing the the killer or whatever
the private eye stuff yeah they
essentially took all of that out but
she's like but
they replaced it with more character
development of the babysitter
prior to her doing the babysitting gig
and she's like and i'm not really sure i
liked that either
um yeah and she said the same thing
she's like in the original film
she's like basically you learn
everything you need to know about carol
kane's character in just a couple of
minutes just from her
the way she talks just from her body
language stuff like that
the babysitter what there's a special
babysitter yeah
babysitter's babes well i mean like i
said that well the first one they
established her character very
uh efficiently and i thought that was
really well done just like with a she
was talking to her friend on the phone
it's like you know everything you need
to know about her yeah and stuff like
that so they
so this girl was kind of like well i
didn't really think even though i
thought that i wanted the whole movie to
be about
the babysitter and you know the the
first 20 minutes of the original film
being the climax of the
of the film she's like but that didn't
really work either because then they had
to fill in too much stuff
that you didn't care about like about
this character you know what i mean you
could have stretched the terrorism out a
little bit longer so that
he was messing with her for more she was
i would
i would have i would have done it so
they were she had she had seen him or
maybe thought what are you doing pope
maybe she sees him a couple times
there's a couple of fights and a couple
of chases inside the house before it
ends you get another 15 minutes out of
that
and then it ends you know with the cops
killing him or something well the thing
about it i mean
there's a whole genre of movies nowadays
like in the last 10 20 years
that are like home invasion horror yeah
that took the concept and made a whole
movie out of it and one of the ones i
was thinking of was mike flanagan's hush
which basically the whole thing was
about like a uh you know a hearing
impaired woman she couldn't hear
anything
and a dude stalking her while she was at
a cabin all by herself and that was the
whole movie and it was great
so it can be done you just kind of have
to know what you're doing
so i kind of feel like this suffered a
little bit from
the you know the short film that they
made being amazing
and then like the rest of it kind of
suffers by comparison and i and i hate
saying that because
i loved all the actors involved it
seemed like a good story on its own but
it
almost seemed like the middle part of it
was like a totally different movie yeah
i'm saying it's like it took two movies
and matched them again yeah because
basically like i said the part everybody
remembers from this movie is the first
20 minutes with carol kane right
and then at the very end of that um you
know the kids get killed
and they catch the killer and then in
the next one in the next segment like in
the second act
you get uh it's seven years later
and you get a thing where the father of
the two kids
that were killed hires charles derning
who was one of the detectives that
worked on the case
originally but is now retired and is now
a private investigator
he's like basically um the dude that did
this was in an asylum for seven years
but then he escaped so now he's running
around loose
so the dad of the kids hires charles
derning to go find the dude and
also kind of like take care of him if
you know what i mean and i don't mean
like take him out on a date they mean
whack him whack that guy
so the whole middle part of the movie is
um the killer basically
he kind of gets out at first and then
he's just you know he runs into this
woman in a bar
uh played by colleen dewhurst and he's
creepy but he's not yet full-on
mad or homicidal because i think one of
the things they establish is that he was
on meds when he was in the hospital
and it's like the longer he's out like
you know the meds are going to wear off
so the crazy is going to come back to
the four
or whatever so they have to like find
him before then
so he kind of starts stalking colleen
dewhurst character
and then she kind of meets the detective
and they kind of team up
a little bit to find uh to find him
although
it seems like she says she's gonna work
with him and like oh i'll help you and
she does this one thing where she goes
back to the bar
where they met and then he's supposed to
because he's like oh maybe the crazy guy
will come there but then he doesn't come
there and then she goes home and then
he's in her apartment and then he runs
away and then you don't see colleen do
her character anymore
which i thought was kind of weird
because i thought that they were just
going to like team up like her in the
detective but that didn't happen
so then it's just kind of like this sort
of cat and mouse
thing where charles darning is trying to
find him
so that's like the whole second act and
like i said it does kind of uh
drag a bit and like i said it's from
like seems like it's from a different
movie
but then when it gets about 15 20
minutes from the end
this is a hugely long movie i think it's
only like an hour and 38 minutes or
something like that
but then when you get to the third act
it actually gets better because then you
get carol kane
comes back into the thing and now she's
seven years older
obviously she has she's married and she
has two kids of her own
and at some point the crazy guy decides
that he's going to
stalk her again and that final sequence
is actually not as awesome as like the
first part
but that final sequence is actually
pretty good like i like the part where
she
thinks somebody's in the house and she's
freaking out and everything and then she
thinks everything's okay because the
kids are okay and then she goes back
into the bed
and then the and then the dude is like
in bed next to her and like that's like
really freaky like that's really good
but i feel well okay one of the things i
don't like and i think i've talked about
this
before i don't like when you
overly explain or you overly humanize
the villain necessarily i i mean i'm not
saying that's a bad thing in principle
i'm just saying that
it's scarier if you don't know who he is
i think so i think like the first part
of the movie is so scary because you
don't
see him all you see you hear his creepy
ass voice on the phone
and then you just see the silhouette
like of the shadow and then she freaks
out and that's like the end of that
best sequence of the movie but then when
they show him just as a person
he's escaped from the hospital he's kind
of living in the streets and like you
know living in homeless shelters and
being weird and creeping on women in
bars and stuff like that
and you know wigging out naked in front
of a bathroom mirror
it's like i'm not saying that that's not
like great characterization
and stuff and you know but it's almost
kind of like the movie's trying to make
you feel
bad for him you know what i mean i kind
of like they were
maybe but it's like i didn't feel bad
yeah it's not effective
because he tore two children up with his
bare hands it's like
if he was mentally ill and he couldn't
help it okay fine but you know what i
mean
you don't want to you don't want to take
the mystery away
yeah i mean that's why you know predator
one and two were so good you didn't know
anything about these aliens
you know kind of like the less you know
about them the better same thing with
terminator lest you know about the
terminator and the damn sky
net the better when you start telling
the whole story
now the mystery just falls apart same
that's the way all
villains are you should just know just
enough
yeah no just enough to make them
compelling yeah but
honestly and particularly as far as
horror movies are concerned
are concerned like slasher movies like
these thriller stalkers
i think like the less information you
give about the villain is probably the
better
i mean maybe people have different
opinions on that um i was just like uh
doing a book review earlier about a book
where some people didn't like
you know oh we don't know anything about
the villain or anything like that but i
liked that because i thought it made it
scarier because you can project your own
[ __ ] onto it
best villain of all time darth vader
from the first three movies
when they started to give too much
backstory about darth vader
nah well i think that's why i mean and i
think i brought this
up before it's like one of the reasons i
really didn't like rob zombie's
halloween remake
is because you know half of the movie it
seemed like at least
was um you know michael myers as a kid
like bnb it's like nobody wants to know
that
he's supposed to be the boogeyman the
shape you're not supposed to know
anything about him
it's like you got just enough
information about him in the original
one yeah he killed his sister when he
was a kid
then he went off to an asylum and then
nobody knows anything about him since
then
uh he just turns up in his boiler suit
and his [ __ ] william shatner mask
and it's creepy as [ __ ] and i think that
if they had kept the tone
in when a stranger calls from the first
20 minutes and like extended through
and i'm not saying that you couldn't
jump ahead in time you totally could
um you could have him menace other
people you there could be like a whole i
mean like i said there have been movies
like this
um but i just kind of feel like
the whole middle part of you know the
private investigator looking for him
and intercutting that with this dude
just like wandering around the city
you know being homeless or whatever um
it really like undercut his
menace i thought because you could see
him and he just seemed kind of
pitiful more than scary you know what i
mean the only
the only villain slash serial killer
where they did
the origin story and a bunch of details
and where it worked
was from hannibal lecter yeah but
yesterday but they did it the right
way i really liked hannibal rising
fantastic movie origin story for
hannibal lecter
um but that was but they never fully
explored that character to the point
where they just demystified him he was
always weird
yeah it's you really have to leave some
mystery like when you're doing a villain
yeah and i feel like that's maybe where
but like you said had they i mean it's
really sad because the guy
that played uh the killer his name was
tony beckley i think
and this was actually he died like i
think only six
months after this movie came out he was
really really sick he was actually
really sick i'm not sure
it was cancer or whatever but um he was
really sick when he was filming this
movie as well and he died not too long
after it came out
so it's like and i'm not saying that the
middle part was like bad performances or
anything like that i'm just saying that
it it seemed like two different types of
movies
that were kind of like mashed together
you know what i'm saying like if you're
gonna do
a sort of police procedural thriller cat
and mouse you know
the detective catching a killer type of
thing um that's also been done and it's
been done well obviously it can be done
you know very well if you know what
you're doing but i feel like this would
have been better
if it had been more concentrated on
being like halloween
you know what i mean like a more
standard slasher movie where you don't
really know anything about the villain
it's just this random ass dude that has
decided to target you
um has killed these two children because
that's great i mean this dude is in the
house
he has killed two children that were
sleeping in bed with his bare hands
and he's just like all covered with
blood no reason no nothing that's
terrifying
um if they had just stuck with that and
not shown him
or at least shown him only in shadow or
just as like they did in black christmas
where you just see his eye
um you know what i mean and you didn't
really know that dude's story either
because like i said i compare it to
black christmas a little bit too because
that was kind of that had a kind of you
know the guys calling from inside the
house aspect as well
so but i think that was done better in
black christmas
but i can see why when a stranger calls
is still
um kind of a cult classic i think it's a
cult classic on the back of that first
20 minutes
because those first 20 minutes are
[ __ ] great i had forgotten
how awesome all of the shots of the
inside of that house are
like when she's getting all the phone
calls i love all those [ __ ]
i love the shots of just like the
darkened house like there's a room back
there and then like you can hear her
talking on the phone
like but you can't see her and it's just
like it's really really good like i
really like the unsettling
vibe of it and she really sells it i
think like just this kind of vulnerable
girl that's like all by herself in this
house that she's not familiar with
and i think everybody can relate to that
so it's really scary
but i don't know it just seemed like
like i said it seemed like two different
movies
which yeah and i had totally forgotten
that it was like that
i thought the whole thing was like
it was a hodgepodge just like they
mashed some stuff together some good
stuff and some
okay stuff i already said what i'm gonna
say about the movie i mean yeah you guys
know
my opinion of it is it worth watching
nah well it depends i mean i think
you're trying to learn something maybe
about film
yeah like i said i think for that first
20 minutes alone and like the last act
is good too
i liked the last act also but it's just
i just felt like it didn't need
the middle part i saw another reviewer
on this and he said a pretty astute
thing
he was just he was like okay i feel like
this was like the first 20 minutes was
like its own movie
and then the middle part was almost kind
of like
this other this so like the middle part
and the end part was almost like a
sequel but it was all in one movie
you know what i mean um which i thought
was pretty astute they did actually make
a sequel
to this called when a stranger calls
back which i think i saw but i can't
really remember much about it i don't
even know if carol kane was in the
sequel or not but um but as i said
they did a remake of it and i heard it
was decent because they did actually
focus more on the babysitter and they
focused on that
um you know that scenario more than like
adding all of this weird detective stuff
in there
um but in a lot of ways that didn't
really work either but for different
reasons
yeah i didn't like it i thought it was
just totally totally inconsistent
it is really good first 20 minutes and
then
the main body of the story is kind of a
meandering
private eye type movie
that is not really all that compelling
but then it then it leads up to a final
confrontation that was
pretty good but i think it had been more
effective had it had they got
rid of the middle part and followed her
character yeah and just
jammed it like that and it would have
been fine
uh but it would have been short it's
just totally inconsistent it's
it's i think it's a good example of how
you can mix some excellent stuff
together with some mediocre stuff and
have the whole thing fail because of it
yeah you know that's that's what i think
you can learn from them i mean as i said
you can watch the first 20 minutes
on its own just as a great horror movie
on its own like a standalone you don't
need the rest of the stuff necessarily
or you can just kind of skip all the
stuff in the middle because it's not
really all that important
um and like i said i think it was kind
of a mistake to show
the killer like as a character just as a
normal guy even though obviously he
would be in real life well you know
what's funny is that that first
20 minutes i thought because i had sort
of saw it a long time ago as a kid
around the city i thought that was part
of maniac
really yeah that was the guy who kept
cutting people's hair
yeah yeah yeah i thought that was a
maniac william lustig yeah i had kind of
merged them together
we should do maniac one of these days i
keep thinking i watched it's pretty good
from what i remember yeah i heard the
remake was okay too
but um i haven't seen the remake but i
like the original a lot
when i saw it i was like oh this is
going to be good i remember this but i
was thinking of maniac
and yeah yeah those are two different
but
yeah he was the one that was scalping
the album people scalping people and
taking pictures it's real sleazy yeah
real sleazy i thought that i thought it
was that movie
yeah but this one i mean it is
the first 20 minutes are so iconic that
uh you know the movie scream the wes
craven movie
um the the first part of that movie is
actually an homage
to this movie you know what i mean where
sydney like played by drew barrymore
gets the phone call and all that kind of
stuff
um he was like homaging this but as i
said it's just
that that first 20 minutes is so good
that i had completely forgotten
that that wasn't the whole movie because
i hadn't seen it in such a long time
so like when i'm watching i'm like wait
seven years later what's going on now
but like i said i kind of feel like had
you taken the detective set and like i
said no [ __ ]
i'm not [ __ ] on charles durning or
you know uh anybody that was
in the middle part of the film because
it was all like it had the dude that
played superfly in there too
yeah he was like one he had kind of a
big part but um
you know nothing against that because
acting was good and stuff like that it
just seemed like it wandered in from
another movie
i think feel like it should have
concentrated you could skip ahead seven
years but i think it should have
concentrated on carol kane's character
the whole time
because you could have totally fleshed
that out you could have even fleshed out
the killer's backstory although i think
in this
instance that probably would have been a
mistake i think it was better to keep
him
uh ambiguous and to keep his motive
unclear
or him not having a motive because like
i said i think that's a lot scarier he's
also not intimidating
looking they should have had a guy that
was big like jason
or his michael myers he just he's not
very intimidating looking guy
he's somebody you could whip his ass
pretty easily well he did get his ass
where he got his ass
yeah when he got out right and like i
said in a way it almost seems weirdly
like
like we were almost supposed to feel
sorry for him because you know the first
thing he does he escapes from the bar or
whatever and he doesn't have any
or escapes from the asylum and he gets
out and then he goes to this bar and
starts creeping on a woman
and then this other dude comes up and
kicks his ass and i'm just kind of like
i don't know i felt like the movie was
trying to get me to feel sorry for him
like yeah i don't he deserved to get his
deathbeat
like creeping on people but you know i
know he couldn't help it but
you know it was just kind of like okay
but yeah i
just really feel like there's a really a
kernel of a great movie in there
um but it just they didn't quite know
what direction to take it so it almost
seemed like they couldn't decide on a
genre
i don't think they had seen enough
examples of what was possible
maybe not you know what i mean it's and
like i said the middle part
could totally be in a different movie
about a different thing because i've
seen other movies like that
that middle part wasn't cheap man they
spent money doing that [ __ ] and the
acting in it was good
and they they bought you know they could
have kept that [ __ ]
real simple and gone the route of
halloween or something
and had a fantastic movie but it hit
well this actually was a hit um
this uh cost uh 1.5 million to make and
it made over 20 million
okay big money which is why they made a
sequel a couple of years later
although like i said i don't remember
anything about the sequel i think it
started going like that first 20 minutes
it would have been like halloween it'd
have been great
yeah well like i said i mean john
carpenter did it with halloween i mean
that's kind of what this move that's why
uh you know fred walton got the idea to
expand his short film
into a longer film because of the
success of halloween he's like oh i can
make something like that
we just have to flesh it out to movie
length it's just i don't think he really
knew how to consistently stay within
that same
genre because it seemed like a couple
different movies going on at the same
time yeah
uh which is a shame uh because
like i said the bookends of this movie
are good and then like the middle
part it just didn't need to be in there
and when you see the villain he's not
real intimidating looking
the [ __ ] that he does isn't very
intimidating he didn't they didn't
really know how to deliver on that
you know compared to michael myers oh
[ __ ] man come on
yeah jason oh well yeah and the reason
why those are scary and the reason why
the first 20 minutes of this is scary is
you don't see them yeah i mean there are
there are masks on or you just see the
shadow
that's like way [ __ ] scarier than
just seeing it and you see them they
actually are frightening looking
yeah you know i mean in jason and
halloway and you're like oh okay yeah
you're dealing with pretty big dude he's
got a [ __ ] machete
and a mask and a bag on his head or
something
yeah that's right which yeah you would
[ __ ] your pants if you saw that in real
life yeah [ __ ] ass ready
that's some scary [ __ ] it's like
something about a chainsaw massacre you
know what i mean that's probably where
they got that idea you know just
just some old [ __ ] from living
out in the woods coming at you with a
machete
machete or a chainsaw there's no
electors no [ __ ] street lights out
there
for you people living up in the hood
street lights won't save you
they're not out there
[Laughter]
they know how to you know we watch that
[ __ ] in the summer when you're [ __ ]
mississippi and chicken you afraid to
look out the window at night
when you were watching that [ __ ] don't
look out the window yeah because you
know
he might stand out there might see
somebody looking back at you
i still think about that every now and
then because like you know because you
usually leave like the the curtains on
the sliding glass door open and every
now and then like oh
and you can see out there because the
moon and everything yeah so it's like
every now and then like if i wake up in
the middle of night to go to the
bathroom like i wonder what i would do
if somebody was just like standing there
looking at it and i feel like
yeah well that's what jason that's what
jason and michael myers were all about
it was dark out there yes they're just
gonna stand there and look at you like
your ass out yeah stand out there and
coveralls and [ __ ]
work boots and nothing good ever comes
no we don't want to cover all of you
he's wearing coveralls or some kind of
[ __ ] overalls or jumpsuit or
something like that you're [ __ ]
yeah and he's got dirty ass [ __ ]
leather boots
and work gloves or something and a bag
on his head yeah you [ __ ] because he's
obviously out for mischief yeah although
i'm not saying that it would be any
better to see a dude in a three-piece
suit standing outside your window
looking creepily and aren't you
that might be james bond but
that's true that might be cooler
you just tell potential talkers take
note some dude just
dressed in farm clothes you know that's
just
more effective yeah because he's gonna
like [ __ ] work he's gonna do some
slaughtering
yeah he can just run through a plate
glass window
not get too cut up and just in there and
look at you got a bag on his head
[Laughter]
that was that was a much better recipe
to get you to fear
the villain yeah than what they showed
in this that's well that's all i'm
saying
yeah okay well as i said they seem to
have you know
they seem to have it down pat in the
beginning part like because that was the
short film you don't see him because you
don't see him
yeah and that was scary as [ __ ] you know
when you hear the voice because i hadn't
seen him in a long time i forgot what
the thing looked like
i pictured a guy and wearing all black
with like a black turtleneck and a big
old [ __ ] kitchen knife
and some kind of a mask you know what i
mean like a white skull mask or
something what it sounds like
which i said hush was kind of like that
he had like a black beanie and like then
he had like a white mouth yeah or like
one of those black [ __ ] ira
[ __ ] you know
yeah like something you see from the ira
or
you know from the troubles [ __ ] you know
looking at you but it's all black you
know that or that'd be like like mr
cruel or like
yeah you know that's what you're
pitching angelo yeah what you really see
is this
wimpy little [ __ ] dude curly hair and
just who's got he's got creepy eyes and
he's creepy but he's more like
he's more like pathetic than
intimidating
physical power which like i said well
it's almost kind of like because they
tell you later you don't see it happen
but they do tell you later that how he
killed the kids was he basically tore
them apart with his bare hands
and which you know that's horrific
but when you see him he doesn't look
like somebody that would do that i mean
they were trying to like make him seem
like he was so
crazy that he was just like had you know
he looks like a dude
insane strength he actually looks like a
dude did creep up on the girls and jerk
off on the bus
yeah yeah which is creepy in its own
right i'm not saying that but he doesn't
look like the type of dude that would
tear kids apart with
exactly what type of guy get his ass
kicked by a girl
he did kind of and i feel kind of like
he like i said he had creepy eyes
and there was like some really effective
sequences like i like the scene
and even in the middle part like where
um you know where he's in
uh colleen duhert's apartment and like
you know like you just see the kind of
door opening he's in there
and like i said the last part of the
movie where he's actually in carol
kane's house with the husband and
everything and like she hears somebody
like
talking from the closet or whatever and
then he's really like in bed with her
and stuff
that part's great but you know so he's
kind of creepy then because he seems
like a crazy person which and you can
and you can put yourself into that
mindset it's like what if you were in
bed and you thought your husband was
there and then it was just this crazy it
wouldn't matter if he was big or not
it's like there's some [ __ ] random
ass crazy stranger in your bed
which is uh you know scary enough on its
own but yeah i think the middle part of
the movie kind of just brought home the
fact that he wasn't
a very intimidating presence it just
made him seem like a pitiful
mentally ill man um which
when i mean you wanted him to be scary
because that was kind of like that's
where you thought the movie was going
for
so it almost wanted to be a slasher
movie at a police procedural at the same
time and it didn't really work out
[ __ ] all this i want to see terror train
again uh
you know uh i think that uh amazon prime
added that
not too long ago maybe yeah we can uh we
can do that
as well that can be one of our reviews
no problem all right so
that will do it for our movie
retrospective today for when a stranger
calls 1979.
uh it's actually on amazon prime as
is the remake uh if you want to check i
don't know if the sequel is
but yeah check them out like i said the
first 20 minutes fantastic iconic
um you know i feel like everybody even
if you haven't seen the movie
like you know about the first 20 minutes
of this movie because they're great uh
the rest of it
you know it's it's it's all right but um
you know
but i feel like you probably should see
at least the first 20 minutes if you're
a horror fan
at all but yeah so that'll do it for
this review and we will see you guys
on the next one bye